look it's a little pregs and big pregs
wait when did we start isn't it amazing
the difference in our sizes A co-worker
of mine is drinking caffeine while
pregnant and I don't know if I should
call social services about it Angela
that's pretty transparently Me Maybe
you know it's just herbal tea
and mugs with Trace Amounts of coffee
yeah I think you should call social
services I already did
just a second
so glad we were finally able to do it no
no okay
what's up tuna we have some tuna for
dinner I bet you're sick of tuna right
probably tuna every night all right
these are for you oh how soft very nice
except for one flower which is for
my flower oh what am I supposed to do
with this
well how about we do the short tour and
then I'll start dinner
oh I can help starting dinner if you
need it oh no no just the asabuko needs
to braise for about three hours
everything else is done
three hours from now or three hours from
earlier like four o'clock
you know Pam in Spain they often don't
even start eating until midnight When in
Rome put a toast did I
here's two good friends
Cheers Cheers
hmm
that is sort of an Oaky after birth
what was that
so music should we turn some music that
sounds good yeah
you guys remember my old assistant
Hunter
excellent songwriter wait did you hear
this
[Music]
you know what Hunter was a terrible
assistant that is why Ryan fired well I
think he's probably just about as
reliable as bam being that it usually
takes you an afternoon to get back to me
sometimes I think she holds on to faxes
[Music]
oh not even close so we keep a very tiny
house we should see our bathroom after
Michael takes a bath
[Laughter]
to tell you Pam yeah yeah
what oh well don't tell me that he's
really changed since you guys dated
oh are you joking Michael told me a
little bit about it but I see the way
you look at him
I have never ever dated or wanted to do
anything resembling dating Michael ever
not ever not now not then not now not
ever ever I've noticed how you look at
him at the office
[Music]
my imagination
can I have your attention please
[Music]
I was waiting for the right time to do
this and
I I can't think of a better time than
right now with the music playing and all
our friends around and fireworks going
off
my parents are here Andrew and Ellen
Bernard thank you for sharing in this
joyous moment
Miss Angela Martin
will you please join me on stage
okay then I will come to you my flower
damn it
Angela
will you do me the honor
of giving me your tiny hand
in marriage
okay
into the mic sweetie I said okay she
said yes
okay
and The Crowd Goes a wild
[Applause]
I needed another hour it could have been
done in another hour I think it looks
good
that's why you're not in charge Meredith
here you are my dear one thing made of
ice
how did you
um where would you just ice melt all
over the floor will you help me put it
over there yes I will okay excuse me
stole it
Philip is so fat Kevin
you warned me not to say anything if it
was Tiny oscar but you didn't prepare me
for a big giant fat baby
can't stay there all day I'm coming
do I at least get to go with you in this
fantasy
just Slow Me Down
Dwight has been acting manager for three
months now
a week just feels like three months
Let's see we all have to punch into a
Time Clock which is very old very strong
and has the slot about the size of a
finger
we were all given new business cards big
enough to set us apart from the
competition which is how I learned that
our titles are all now Junior employee
our lunch breaks are staggered to
prevent wasting time
mine's at 10 30. and I find that the
first hour of the day goes by a lot
quicker than the second seven hours stop
stalling
come on
hey Kathy hi how's it going everything
makes sense I think everything is under
control great you should sit down oh no
I'm fine no I should go fill out my
paperwork
okay
oh that was just me
pregnant Pam
and it makes sounds much worse than this
oh we know
I'm training attempt to be my
replacement while I'm on maternity leave
oh I should have mentioned I'm pregnant
you probably didn't notice because it's
impossible to tell because I'm so small
but yeah I'm pregnant
oh come on
it's just absurd yes because she's hot
right her breasts are large her waist is
small her reproductive health and ample
evidence and facial symmetry come on
the thing about pregnancy is people
treat you differently like you're a kid
almost they lose all sense of boundaries
they start acting weird telling you
things that clearly aren't true
I know it sounds nuts but I think Dwight
is the only one who's telling me the
truth
Dwight
am I hot right now why would I or anyone
else think that you're hot right now I
can't impregnate you and that's the
driving force between male female
attraction what about before was I
attractive before yeah
you're right you're most attractive and
you are 24 with a slight gradual decline
and steep drop off when you got pregnant
for the first time gradual recovery and
uh well now obviously you're at an
all-time low